le 24 février 2003 dans la petite ville
de saulieu au coeur de la bourgogne sur
le plateau du morvan un drame se joue un
drame humain un drame familial
un homme père de famille chefs
d'entreprise se donne la mort cet homme
s'appelle bernard loiseau
c'est le chef de cuisine le plus connu
en france le plus médiatique celui qui
porte l'image de la gastronomie
française
il se donne la mort pour des raisons
pour des raisons tout à fait
personnelles lendemain matin ses équipes
une centaine de personnes sont réunies à
ce lieu dans le restaurant et vivent ces
drames essaye de survivre à ces drames
d'une certaine manière
et puis décide de continuer de continuer
son oeuvre parce que ils ne veulent pas
que bernard oiseaux meurent une deuxième
fois
mais derrière c'est cet engagement à
continuer se pose une question
fondamentale est un espèce de paradoxe a
fait jour ainsi rapidement c'est que
l'ensemble des équipes à la conviction
qu'ils savent faire
monsieur l'oiseau était suffisamment un
aspirant monsieur l'oiseau était
suffisamment dans une logique de
délégation pour qu'ils aient la
conviction de savoir faire tourner le
restaurant pour qu'ils aient la
conviction de savoir fait retourner
l'hôtel mais néanmoins malgré cette
conviction il se pose cette question est
ce qu'on sera capable de continuer sans
lui cette question a une portée beaucoup
plus fondamentale au delà de ce drame
d'entreprise au delà de cette
problématique d'entreprise
cette question à une problématique
fondamentale a une portée beaucoup plus
fondamental qui est la question que se
posent beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont
confrontés à l'innovation aujourd'hui
dans quelle mesure l'entreprise
l'organisation elle-même peut-elle
porter l'innovation la capacité
d'innovation
la question qui se pose c'est celle du
rapport entre le talent l'individu donc
bernard loiseau qui étaient tous dans
cette entreprise qui était le chef
charismatique celui pour lequel on se
levait le matin qui était le créateur
c'est lui qui avait des idées géniales
de plaques à être qu'ils allaient être
mis à la carte
le communicant celui qui passe à la
radio le dimanche pour dire aux gens
venez et pour le transmettre sa passion
et pour transmettre aux gens l'envié de
venir goûter ce qui fait et le manager
charismatique il était aussi évidemment
le chef d'entreprise et donc quand cet
individu le talent disparaît qu'est ce
qui reste dans l'entreprise
qu'est ce qui reste de sa capacité
d'innovation qu'est ce qu'il reste de sa
capacité de création
c'est la question qui se pose très très
concrètement à l'entreprise bernard
loiseau est derrière cette question
c'est la question du rapport entre eux
talent individus et processus entre la
dimension individuelle et la dimension
collective de la création j'ai été
interpellé par cette problématique
d'entreprise qui faisait écho à des
enjeux beaucoup plus fondamentaux comme
je les dis qui faisait écho au chili à
mon parcours très jeune j'ai été
passionné par deux choses d'abord la
chose organisationnel comment on arrive
à faire travailler des gens ensemble ce
qui est ce qui me passionne toujours
autant
et puis fasciné par des activités
particulières qui sont les activités de
création que l'on trouve dans la cuisine
mais aussi dans le parfum dans le jeu
vidéo de la mode dans le cinéma dans le
design et j'ai fait finalement j'ai
construit mon métier autour de ces deux
activités en mission de comprendre
finalement comment les organisations
arriver à se construire autour de cette
activité de création et ce drame dans
l'entreprise bernard loiseau arrivée
pour moi comme une espèce de à la fois
de défis et de et de bouées
défi parce que dans mon parcours de
chercheur en gestion je m'intéressais au
processus aux organisations et
finalement en mettant un petit peu à
l'écart les individus quand on regarde
les choses avec un oeil de gestionnaires
ou d'organisateurs
finalement les individus peuvent être
considérés comme substituables la notion
de talent pose question c'est que c'est
quoi un talent on sait pas trop donc on
se focalise plutôt sur les sur les
organisations et les processus
hélas ce drame va ramener cette question
du talent en avant et en disant voilà
que quelle place à cet individu par
rapport au reste de l'organisation est
en fait la question s'est posée
évidemment de vos sens quelle place quel
rôle joue l'organisation et les
processus dans une entreprise qui est
créative alors là après cet engagement
la question une des questions qui se
posent et c'est qui va remplacer bernard
loiseau dans ses différentes fonctions
et notamment en cuisine la fonction de
création
et là la réponse paraît évidente
patrick bertrand et son second depuis 21
ans patrick bertron dirige les cuisines
patrick bertron propose des plats qui
sont mis à la carte et patrick bertrand
a la réputation de faire du bernard
loiseau mieux que bernard loiseau
donc évidemment la question ne se pose
quasiment pas ça paraît évident pourtant
alors j'ai rencontré l'ensemble des
équipes et notamment patrick pourtant
quand on y pose quand on lui pose la
question il accepte mais dans sa tête
la question qu'il se pose c'est est ce
que je suis capable
deuxième paradoxe qui fait écho qui fait
écho au premier et pourquoi il ne
serait-il pas capables ils s'étaient
tous il crée il dirigeait les cuisines
et ses plats été mis à la carte est en
fait cette interrogation fondamentale
est à peu près la même que celle que
j'ai posée tout à l'heure c'est dire le
rôle des processus de l'organisation par
rapport au talent quand on analyse les
choses on se rend compte qu'ils
faisaient presque tout qu'est-ce qu'il
ne faisait pas à patrick proposer des
plats et au final celui qui s'est engagé
pour dire c'est ce plat la wii qu'on va
mettre à la carte
c'était bernard loiseau
et tout le désarroi de l'organisation
dans ce contexte c'est finalement le
désarroi d'une organisation a perdu la
personne qui portait une vision et qui
l'a transmettez à l'ensemble de ses
équipes et qui emmenait toute une
organisation
derrière cette vision une vision
parfaitement subjective plat meilleures
que d'autres n'est pas une direction
meilleure qu'une autre mais il avait
fait fonction et cette capacité à
emmener les équipes derrière sa vision
subjective
patrick bertrand est il capable de faire
ça lui-même ne le sait pas puisque il
n'a jamais été en situation de le faire
à partir du moment où je dois décider si
le plat que j'ai conçu mérite d'être à
la carte
la phrase qu'il utilise est est ce que
mon palais sera à la hauteur d'un
restaurant trois étoiles il n'a jamais
été dans cette situation de décider donc
se doute qu'il habite se comprend
aisément
et ça nous dit beaucoup sur la capacité
créative des organisations elle repose
aussi sur ces individus qui ont cette
capacité a affirmé une voix une
subjectivité donc patrick bertron
reprend les cuisines crée d'abord
commencé à reproduire les recettes de
bernard loiseau pour rassurer pour
assurer l'ensemble de l'environnement et
petit à petit puisque c'est une
ordination de création est amené à
proposer des plats nouveaux et puis
quelques mois après un nouveau drame qui
n'a pas la même ampleur que le précédent
évidemment se joue dans cette même
entreprise
le bras droit de bernard loiseau celui
qui dirige le restaurant commence à
retoquer les plats de patrick bertrand
non ce n'est pas du bernard loiseau tu
ne respectes pas l'identité du
restaurant et donc ces deux personnes
qui s'affrontent deux personnes qui y
ont été compagnon de route de bernard
loiseau de personnes qui l'ont
accompagné depuis plus de 20 ans et
chacun avec une perception très
différente de ce qu'il faut faire de ce
qu'on doit faire
où est la vérité il n'y a pas de vérité
absolument pas de vérité pas de juge de
paix le seul juge de paix
malheureusement est décédé
et donc la question que tout ça pose
c'est comment dans ce contexte où il n'y
a pas de vérité qui s'imposent objectif
comment organiser la décision dans ses
activités de création le choix qui a été
fait c'est de dire la maison doit
avancer doit aller de l'avant on a
décidé qu'on avait un créateur et donc
on lui donne les mains libres et donc à
partir de ce moment là c'est lui qui
doit décider le directeur du restaurant
historique a été mis à l'écart
deuxième drame ou troisième drame pour
cette maison et puis le l'établissement
a continué à continuer son aventure
quand on se penche un peu plus
précisément sur comment ce produit
l'activité de création en fait c'est une
activité collective
en tout cas dans le fonctionnement de
patrick aujourd'hui il s'appuie sur deux
secondes des jeunes qui sont très
talentueux qui ont très très beau
parcours dans des grandes maisons qui
vont le nourrir apporter leurs idées
apporter leurs connaissances à apporter
leur expertise qui est un peu différente
de la sienne puisqu'il en un peu moins
de l'expérience et le processus est le
suivant patrick bertron propose un thème
qui est souvent autour d'un produit star
les produits qu'on s'attend à trouver
dans un grand restaurant comme celui de
la côte d'or à saulieu par exemple les
maury et puis les idées fusent et les
second apport différentes idées sur
quelles techniques sur quel
accompagnement sur quelle façon de
rester et c'est tout ça dans un jeu de
d'allers retours très très rapide dans
lequel le chef patrick bertron a un rôle
particulier
c'est qu'ils jouent une espèce de rôle
de gars de tri donc les idées il les
prend il les entend et lit oui non oui
non peut-être oui mais il faut creuser
on approfondit et là encore on voit
apparaître voit se dessiner ce qu'est le
rôle du créateur par rapport au
collectif
donc on est dans une activité collective
mais dans lequel un individu a un rôle
particulier
et ce rôle du créateur c'est cette
décision finale
la décision qui a qui finalement
apparaît tout au long du processus qui
consiste à assembler prendre
sélectionner les idées et en creusant en
creusant avec lui ce qu'il apparaisse et
que sur quoi repose cette décision sur
plusieurs éléments d'abord une expertise
technique c'est que tu es le produit ne
fonctionnera pas avec tel mode de
cuisson et ça c'est une expérience
accumulée qui s'appuie sur une à la fois
une énorme connaissance et une grande
ouverture qui qui conduit l'ensemble des
créateurs en toujours se renouveler
il ya toujours s'enrichir de
connaissances nouvelles et puis
intervient une deuxième dimension qui
est une dimension parfaitement
subjective et il a dans sa tête une
ligne plus ou moins précises sur ce
qu'il a envie de faire qui sait plus ou
moins formalisés et les propositions qui
lui sont faites rentrer ou pas dans
cette ligne et ils jouent ce rôle de
garant d'une ligne directrice qui encore
une fois se formalise aussi au fil de
l'eau et cette subjectivité est
fondamentale pourquoi parce que dans la
création il ya une forme d'un confort à
assumer un confort ya pas de vérité
telle l'idée était le meilleur que de
colo que tel autre nom mais à un moment
donné il ya une cohérence est le seul
garant de la cohérence c'est moi et mon
intimité et ma subjectivité profonde et
mon histoire profonde et donc on voit se
dessiner la ce
cet équilibre entre la dimension
collective la dimension basé sur des
processus et une organisation de la
création et la dimension individuelle
avec ce rôle essentiel accordée à la
subjectivité
moi je parlais de vision tout à l'heure
bernard loiseau emmenait ses équipes
dans le cadre d'une vision il s'agit pas
voir l'avenir les créateurs ne voit pas
l'avenir les créateurs propose un chemin
dans laquelle ils emmènent leur équipe
et l'essentiel étant que les équipes
adhèrent à ce cheval à une autre une
autre caractéristique des créateurs
c'est qu'ils sont confrontés finalement
à dans cet inconfort à 3 réalité la
première réalité celle de la matière
c'est à dire que quand on a une idée il
va falloir faire en sorte que cette idée
résiste à la matière si je veux cuisiner
l'emory de telle façon
il faudra ensuite quand concrètement
quand on cuisinera l'emory que ça
fonctionne
faudra que les équipes en cuisine au
moment du coup de feu quand les clients
sont là soit capable avec leurs
compétences avec le temps qu'ils ont de
réaliser le la proposition la deuxième
réalité qui s'impose face aux créateurs
c'est la réalité de l'organisation
et c'est ce qu'on voit quand patrick
bertron propose des plats impôts dassieu
qui sortent peut-être de la ligne
historique de laon à l'oiseau et que
l'organisation arrive et lui dit non ça
c'est pas du bernard loiseau
ce retour est classique dans n'importe
quelle organisation
hier que l'organisation bien vous
rappeler que vous êtes en train de vous
éloigner de tout ce qu'on a fait par le
passé et la troisième réalité qui
s'impose à créateurs à patrick en
l'occurrence c'est celle du marché c'est
à dire que il a beau affirmer une ligne
particulière sa subjectivité mettre son
idée précise
faire en sorte qu'elles soient réalisées
que l'organisation ne la détruise pas
ensuite sur à la sanction du marché
c'est-à-dire les clients adopteront ou
non la proposition et tout ça se traduit
par cet inconfort terrible et qui
définit même l'activité de création
et qui consiste à faire des choix dans
une situation d'incertitude parfaite et
ça c'est une qualité extrêmement rare et
extrêmement difficile la lafa n'y a pas
de faire l'histoire mais la suite de
l'histoire qu'est ce que c'est quinze
ans après l'établissement à perdre une
étoile pour différentes raisons que les
équipes n'ont pas forcément encore
encore comprise entre temps patrick
bertron avait conservé les étoiles
pendant au moins 13 ans donc même plus
que bernard loiseau le groupe bernard
loiseau a cédé deux restaurants à
racheter ou recréer deux autres
restaurants s'est engagé l'an dernier
dans un projet extrêmement ambitieux
audacieux de création d'un autre
restaurant à saulieu à côté du
restaurant historique qui s'appelle
l'oiseau des séances et qui est un
restaurant axé sur à la fois santé et
plaisir est adossé à un spa immense qui
a donné lieu à des 1500 mètres carrés
qui a donné lieu à des investissements
considérables
est ce que ces choix étaient pertinents
c'était des choix audacieux dans la
mesure où ils sont a su il ya toujours
il ya toujours des raisons de les
contester
mais c'est des choix qui ont été pris
par la maison aujourd'hui sur lesquelles
se sont engagées l'ensemble des équipes
avec des résultats plutôt positifs et ce
qui montre c'est que si on revient sur
la question de départ qui était est ce
que maintenant que bernard loiseau n'est
plus là on a encore cette capacité par
aller de l'avant à prendre des décisions
à être créatifs ou innovants la suite de
l'histoire a montré que oui cette
entreprise aujourd'hui a réussi ce
challenge extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]